South Koreans are not having enough
babies which is a big problem for the
military look at this wild chart this is
how many babies South Koreans are having
and you can see that it dips below this
line which means South Koreans are
having less than one child per woman
this is a big crisis for the South
Korean military because South Koreans
are required to serve in their military
but in the next 50 years the number of
people able to serve is going to be cut
in half meanwhile the nuclear armed
neighbor to the north has one of the
largest armies in the world so one group
of South Koreans came up with a solution
the senior Army 500 seniors like average
age 63 have formed a volunteer group to
train for military action they're not
affiliated with the official Army but
their goal is to be prepared to fight in
case there is a conflict so as South
Korea's population dwindles because of
this low birth rate seniors might be the
solution to the Army if you want to
better understand global politics follow
along for more